the hustle and bustle of the holiday
season it's easy to let healthy habits
Fall by the wayside the king and queen
right now this is for us registered
dietitian Mia sin has tips on how to
stay on top of your Wellness all season
long
hey Las Vegas now I have tips to keep
Wellness top of Mind during the hustle
and bustle of the busy holiday season
starting with a crowd-pleasing side dish
made with ingredients that may help
support immune Health to make this
quinoa tabbouleh salad with grapes
tossed together halved red and green
grapes diced cucumber chopped parsley
dill and mint and quinoa with olive oil
lemon juice and zest salt pepper Ginger
and cumin California grapes are
available in red green and black with
varying flavors shapes sizes and
textures fresh grapes can be used in
dishes of all kinds and can be roasted
pickled grilled baked and more studies
even suggest that grapes may help
support a healthy immune system thanks
to Resveratrol and certain flavonoids
that they contain next support your
immune Health on the go the immunity
boosts spray by orlo nutrition delivers
B vitamins and vitamin D3 in two daily
sprays using Icelandic Ultra spirulina
as a delivery platform a type of algae
that's rich in protein vitamins minerals
and antioxidants plus the vertical Farm
where the spirulina grows uses so few
resources that it has no carbon
footprint it's also carry-on friendly
and perfect for travel you can find it
on Amazon and at orlonutrition.com
next support both your immune and
digestive health with pre and probiotics
probiotics are beneficial bacteria found
in fermented foods like yogurt kimchi
and sauerkraut that may help support
Digestive and immune Health while
prebiotics are a type of fiber found in
foods like asparagus and artichokes that
help fuel those good bacteria if you
don't consume these Foods often consider
trubiotics a science-backed probiotic
supplement line that works naturally to
support both Digestive and immune Health
trubiotics sugar-free gummies feature
the most clinically researched bacillus
probiotic spores designed to withstand
their journey through the body to land
where they're needed in the
gastrointestinal tract so they can help
support healthy microbiome diversity you
can find true biotics on Amazon and
locally at Walmart
finally take trash off your to-do list
this holiday season by turning food
waste into fertilizer Lomi smart waste
composter is the world's first smart
waste kitchen appliance eliminate
garbage at the push of a button which
turns your food waste and more including
produce meat Dairy and even compostable
Plastics and packaging into fertilizer
for your plants and Lawn you can find
loamy on Amazon and at Best Buy
I hope you enjoyed these Wellness tips
for the busy holiday season for more
Wellness tips easy recipes and meal
ideas you can pre-order my new book
mostly plant-based on
amazonbarnesandnoble.com and wherever
books are sold